[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do you remember the days when the first
quarter of the year was super light on
new releases well that's totally not the
case anymore I mean look no further than
the nintendo switch if you want to keep
up with all the hottest games dropping
every week be sure to hit that subscribe
button okay let's do this a new zelda
game launching with a new nintendo
console yes please The Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild is the biggest Zelda
title to date with a massive open world
full of shrines to explore items to
craft bosses to fight and secrets to
discover unlike past Zelda games that
have a clear path from dungeon to
dungeon breath of the wild drops you
into the deep end and lets you explore
at your own pace we don't know much
about the world you'll be exploring but
we do know that it's being lorded over
by the evil calamity gannon breath of
the wild launches with the switch on
Friday March third before Nintendo
dominates your weekend there's another
massive world to explore on the Sony
side of things horizon zero dawn is set
in the post post apocalypse by which I
mean a world populated by both giant
futuristic robot dinosaurs and humans
reverting to a hunter-gatherer society
so what happened to our world how can
humans even fight these giant robo dinos
what other secrets are out there you can
find out for yourself when horizon zero
dawn comes exclusively to ps4 on Tuesday
februari 28 we gave her eyes and a 9 out
of 10 at gamespot so check out that
review for more speaking of old things
coming back torment tides of numenera is
a spiritual successor to 1999's
planescape torment the isometric RPG
puts you in the shoes of the last cast
off an amnesiac who was once possessed
by a super powerful God numenera is all
about storytelling so in between quests
and combat you'll be making plenty of
dialogue Tori choices as for the action
you can play as a warrior wizard or row
armed with weapons and relics that
unlock based on how your choices affect
those around you torment tides of
numenera comes to ps4 xbox one and pc on
februari 28 now back to the switch and
if there's one game showing off what the
new joy con controllers can do it's one
to switch this goofy collection of 28
mini-games asks you to eat sandwiches
swing katana spin plates milk cows and
more and you can do it all in a team
versus mode that plays a bit like a
board game check out our 12 switch
livestream if you want a deeper look and
if it seems like the party game you've
been looking for you can pick it up with
nintendo's new console on March third
let's wrap it up with one more switch
game super Bomberman r celebrates the
series 33rd anniversary with the tried
and true bomb dropping gameplay we've
seen since 1984 you can clear all 50
stages in the fully voice-acted story
mode alone or play co-op with a friend
and if you want to turn things around
and battle each other you can totally do
that too with up to 8 players super
Bomberman are launches alongside the
switch on March third and those are the
big games will be playing this week as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings enter subject
to change thanks for watching guys and
I'll see you next week
[Music]